[Musique]
et j'en parlais à l'instant c'est le
moment de notre rendez-vous junior le 28
mai c'est la fête des mères plus que
neuf jours pour trouver une idée cadeau
peut-être que vous avez envie de le
réaliser vous même cette année c'est le
thème de notre rendez-vous junior de
cette semaine mes amis vous avez une
courte activités manuelles de nous
proposer tout à fait alors des idées de
cadeaux à faire soi même on trouve des
dizaines sur internet en cas de panne
d'inspiration un petit tour sur son
ordinateur et le tour est joué alors
celle que je vous le propose c'est le
site dix doigts point fr qu'il a créée
une pince à linge coeur à faire pour
tous les âges
voilà c'est pas très compliqué d'un
million seller peuvent la faire tout
seul les plus petits par contre faut
être accompagné d'un adulte parce qu'on
utilise des ciseaux c'est rapide
d'affaires elle est aussi simple aussi
toute simple et demande peu de matériel
et ce matériel vous l'avait ramené alors
en plateau donc que ce qu'on trouve là
des ciseaux de la colle de la peinture
voit la chose assez classique moi je la
sais ce que vous avez cités c'est de ce
qui est classique après il faut une
pince à linge en bois ce qui va nous
permettre de faire bouger le petit car
il nous faut aussi du papier cartonné
rouge et blanc vous allez voir plus tard
pourquoi et des ciseaux crantés savez
pour faire les petites vagues et
petrella dont il a fait un peu de
matériel mais le tout ça fait une
dizaine d'euros
une fois qu'on a tout ça on peut
commencer à ces ruptures commencé à
créer alors la première étape c'est tout
simple vous dessiner sur votre feuille
rouge un coeur alors le site créatif
propose lui de faire un choeur d'environ
8 cm de haut et vous le découper avec un
ciseau normal et ensuite
et ensuite du coup c'est l'étape
peinture tout à fait alors à l'image
vous allez le voir là je suis encore en
train de découper mais j'ai choisi - du
papier blanc pour profiter un peu plus
du plaisir de pain alors une fois le
coeur peint en rouge c'est au tour de la
pince à linge n'oubliez pas d'en mettre
jusque dans l'intérieur parce qu'après
l'avoir que ça sèche pour que vous
ouvriez on ne voyais pas trop de blancs
et une fois pas tout ça vous laissez
sécher la pince à linge et le coeur lui
le coupé alors il ya beaucoup ça
beaucoup d'avant sur la sur les images
mais
vous allez on sait la partie un peu plus
technique il va falloir connais la
partie basse en bas de la pince à linge
la partie autant au fait attention que
tout se colle pour que les dents ou
puissent quand on ouvre faire vraiment
une bouche et ensuite vous coller l mes
yeux et non qu'ensuite donc on a notre
petit mot d'amour originale donc quoi de
mieux pour célébrer la fête des mères
merci en tout cas bel nous avoir
présenté cette activité c'est maintenant
l'heure de notre agenda avec deux
derniers rendez vous à noter